so much has happened over the last few
days and one of those things is that a
plant from a totally whacked-out
extremist group called LaRouche PAC
asked the crazy question at an
Alexandria Acacio cortez town hall and
the whole point of it was to make people
who believe in climate change look crazy
and the reactions from the right have
been incredibly laughable but also
almost concerning and how pathological
they are let me explain it all to you
LaRouche PAC has been around a long time
it's associated with a guy named Lyndon
LaRouche who died about eight months ago
it's a wacky group you can research it
you'll very quickly figure out how crazy
the group is they are now a pro Trump
group that is skeptical of climate
change Alexandria Acacio Cortez had a
town hall in Queens New York City so
they thought let's send someone there
let's have him act crazy and we'll make
people who believe in climate change
look really really bad so they send in a
woman wearing a t-shirt that says save
the planet eat the children to get up
and to ask a question and to say hey we
need to really save the planet we need
to start eating babies and Alexandria
Acacio Cortez reacts the way a normal
person would react when you see someone
that could be completely unstable you
can't tell and what you do is you don't
react much at all in order to avoid
further escalating them take a look at
what went down including the question
and AOC s reaction climate crisis we
only have a few months left I love that
you support the Green Deal but it's not
get it you know get it with a fossil
fuel it's not gonna solve the problem
fast enough a Swedish professor saying
that we can eat their dead people but
that's not fast enough so I think you're
next our campaign slogan has to be this
we got to start eating babies we don't
have enough time there's too much co2
all of you your you know your pollutant
too much co2 we have to start now please
you are so great I'm so happy that you
really support a nuclear deal but it's
not enough you know even if we would Bob
Russia
we still have too many people too much
pollution so we have to get rid of the
babies that's a big problem just
stopping a baby's a signing lap we need
to eat the babies I'm just very pleased
it can snow thank you thank you we'll go
ahead okay no we'll go ahead it's a no
no no thank you so I think um yeah no so
one of the things that's very important
to us is that we need to treat the
climate crisis with the urgency that it
does presents so as the woman was
eventually I believe escorted out
because people in the room could tell
something is clearly wrong with this
person and her presence is making
everyone uncomfortable
AOC starts giving some general answer
about climate change and there are
trumpets and right-wingers who have the
nerve to say why didn't I OC denounce
baby eating why didn't I OC say no we
shouldn't eat babies and children are
you people this stupid I mean seriously
are it criticized aoc for policy
criticized her because you think she's
wrong about this or that political
position criticized her for something
that makes sense but she didn't properly
denounce baby eating and answered it as
if it were a normal question this person
was eat from now we know it was a plant
but from the second she starts talking
it's either a plant or someone who is so
mentally ill that you don't want to do
anything that could even possibly
agitate them and aoc did exactly the
right thing when people approached me on
the subway or wherever and something is
very clearly wrong with them or they are
furious and and you know it just doesn't
make any sense and you can't tell is
this person dangerous is this person
mentally ill I can't tell and they spout
some government conspiracy theory do you
think I respond to them about the
specifics of the conspiracy that they
are touting no you do what you can to
de-escalate and initially it was
believed that this was merely a mentally
ill person it
was later found out that it was someone
from LaRouche PAC they might also be
mentally ill they've been doing this eat
the children thing elsewhere there is a
picture there's actually a number of
pictures of people wearing the exact
same t-shirts canvassing out on the
streets so AOC did the right thing she
handled it correctly
stop being losers and go complain about
something else I mean seriously and you
know I don't know sometimes you this is
concern trolling where the right-wingers
and the Trump is who are saying oh my
goodness AOC didn't even have the
decency to denounce baby eating
sometimes they're not being genuine its
concern trolling they're pretending to
be worried could AOC maybe actually be
in favor of baby eating or does AOC
maybe really think that baby eating is a
way to save the planet or whatever I
actually think that there are some
trumpets that are so diluted and so
malignantly disconnected from the
realities of how to deal with people in
the real world that they're not concern
trolling when they say why didn't I OC
denounced the baby eating they are
actually so disconnected from reality
that they just see evil they see
wrongdoing they see misdeeds in
everything in everything that some
something like somebody like AOC does
and that's why you can't convince those
people to change their mind and vote the
right way in November of 2020 that is
why we have to go around them or through
them not with them to defeat Donald
Trump in November of 2020 it's sad but
it's the reality ever wonder why
traditional button-up shirts look so
long and baggy the reason is they
weren't meant to be worn that way untuck
'it is the brand you've been looking for
because they were specifically designed
to be worn untucked this is the original
untucked shirt it's a modern solution to
an old problem
no tucking or tailoring required size
and shape doesn't matter
the shirts are the perfect untucked
length with more than 50 fit
combinations untuck it shirts look great
on tall
short slim and athletic guys of all ages
and you can shop online or visit one of
untuk it's stores I now have a short
sleeve and long sleeve button-up untuck
it shirts some polo shirts and a bunch
of others they fit me perfectly
people see them they say that shirt
looks like it fits great and it does and
it's so easy for me to just go online
get the designs I want it fits my frame
perfectly the materials are good and I
love the design try it on in person at
one of untuk it's fifty stores or do
what I did go to on Tucket comm to get
started they offer free shipping and
returns on all orders in the US and you
can save 20% on that first order using
my code Pakman at checkout
that's un tu CK IT promo code Pakman PA
que ma N